j'aimerais nuancer peut-être l'argument
de l'engagement et de la visioconférence
je pense que Madame et et Messieurs les
maires en visioconférence ne sont pas
plus désengagé que nous et et en ce sens
la visionférence doit être un outil qui
qui doit être utilisé àon é alors
peut-être pas illimité j'entends bien
mais peut-être réfléchir à des à des
quotas des possibilités de de de séance
et je pense puisque ça se fait même en
commission dans les commissions sport et
les commissions thématiques local
pourquoi pas ne pas le faire pour les
conseils locaux je pense que c'est une
nécessité et ça reviendrait aussi à à
développer ce statut l'élu étudiant
parce qu'il y a des étudiants qui
étudient très loin et qui ne peuvent pas
prendre le train l'avion pour revenir en
conseil municipal départemental ou
régional